Quick. Pause. Thank you so much, Squarespace for sponsoring this video.
Enjoy the video. Cool.
All right. So welcome to my channel. So can you tell me a blue,
little bit about yourself? We know that you're a competitive programmer,
but just a little bit about your life. I am coming or a Richter.
Uh, and I liked competitive programming, uh,
to the degree that I decided to work in competitive programming. Um,
so not only I participate in those contests,
I also organize the contest programming camps, uh,
preparing for IOI for Olympics for high schoolers.
Right now I'm in USA for Google cogent because I advanced to the finals.
And this is some part of my life that a few times a year,
I go to some international competition. Uh,
plus I have a YouTube channel where I teach algorithms.
Nice. So Google code jam. What does it take to get to the final?
Cause I never even got past the preliminary.
Sure. Basically.
It's not about maybe preparing something for the few days before the contest.
It's about being very good in allegories.
And obviously for that you need years to practice. Maybe not, if you are a very,
very good. And then there are several other qualification rounds, I think,
free plus one extra preliminary qualification round.
And then to 25 people I think advance to the finals. That's it?
Just 25, I think 25 plus the champion from the period previous year.
So 26.
Who was the champion from the previous year [inaudible].
And actually he was drinking for the last five years.
Oh my God. So he doesn't need to take the preliminary rounds.
He just goes straight to the final. Yeah. Cool. Cool.
So can you talk to me more about what is competitive programming? Exactly.
Yeah. I think in sharp,
it's a mind sport where instead of like interests are
poker, you think about cards on your next moves here.
You think about programming, how to program something.
You were given a few problems to solve. Uh,
we've some timely meet constraints for data, how big it can be.
You need to invent quick enough algorithm efficient enough and implemented in
time and who is fastest and solves the most problems with.
Do they usually care about the time it takes to execute
or just the complexity?
That's a good question and complexities very important because it's a
difference of ranking one second or one hour or a day.
And there is usually a time limit, like two seconds,
as long as you are within that time limit, you are okay.
There are some competitions where it might matter or also maybe length of count
how good scarier program produces,
because this is some NP hard problem that doesn't have an exact
solution. It's just how solution you will find.
But most of the time is just, you need to pass it.
Then you get the number of points that is assigned to this problem.
So for example, Google code jam at the end, in the final,
how did you guys compare programs? Is it mostly on the time or the correctness?
This is one of those where it's only the correctness and uh,
running within time. And then every problem has some score assigned.
Like this one is 15 pounds. This one is 20 because it's harder.
And the hardest is say 40.
And the sum of points matters. If there is a tie,
what happens of course then when you submit it,
like your last solution means somebody finished in two and half
hours, then he's better than somebody who got the same scurry four hours.
Oh, so, okay. So how fast you do it matters? Yeah.
What do you think you're going to place?
I think around top down, this should be my expected last year.
I was second just after [inaudible].
That is crazy.
This was my one of highest performers in my life. It's not about,
I expect to repeat that. I hope. Of course.
So can you give me an example of what a competitive programming problem is?
Okay. I will give you, I think a cool example. I probably can't solve it,
but let's try. I think you can. Okay.
It will show some point of mine. Okay. Let's say there is,
there was a tennis match or it can be volleyball.
And you're given the secrets of, uh, letters.
I ended up whoever player a or scarred the point,
and there are some rules in tennis. Like you need some,
some number of points to win a set than game match. I don't know. I don't know.
Where was myself? Okay.
You're given like sequence for the whole match and you need to tell which player
won, like won the whole game. Exactly. Hunt.
Of course you can implement all of that to say now, of course,
if there is a tie at the end of Saturday,
they still need to play maybe for a long time.
It's not like whoever gets four points or whatever means immediately.
And you can implement that in say 10 minutes. Right?
I mean, yeah, well, I'm going to do, it's very, very simple. Right.
We have a string of like a BA BA BA B,
and then because I know the rules of tennis.
Imagine if I do know the rules of tennis,
I'm just going to increment the points. And then if it's a set,
they already won the set. It's just like, okay, he wants to set.
So just live there.
Right? Exactly. So you would do that.
And usually what happens during contests is that you see a problem.
You think for a moment about how to implement it,
to implement maybe the back for a little bit, uh, you spend say 10 minutes,
you look at the leaderboard and you saw the,
you see that somebody solved it in 30 seconds.
How is it possible? You might ask.
Oh, did they have like preset code that they already wrote?
Uh, not necessarily. Maybe it's about like, uh,
pasting the in C plus plus include something. Wait,
so.
When you mean 30 seconds,
do you mean the run-time was 30 seconds or do they submit it in 30 seconds?
You've read the problem and implemented and hit submit in France because they
already heard the question. No,
it's about quickly coming up with a simple idea.
And here the idea is that you bring the last letter.
Oh, because, Oh yeah. Cause if you already won, you're the one that ends. Yeah.
And if this drink is AB whatever happens and at the end there is. Yeah.
Well that's, that's assuming, that's assuming the string is correct.
That's a good point.
There's some say these advantage of people used to competitive programming is
that they always assume that data is correct.
Some of the statements said something that there is that sequence describing the
image. Or if the, see,
if the statement said that you are given a sequence of numbers that are in this
entire interval, they will be in this interval.
They don't care about incorrect characters, maybe some number, uh,
being non integer. They just do what they are told.
So they might miss something in real job when they should ask. What if my,
what if user will give me incorrect date?
Um, I add super smart. Yeah. Just look at the last letter of the string he won.
Yeah. That person won. Cool. I like that. This is fun. Okay.
And then would you say,
would you say competitive programmers make good software engineers or it there's
no relation?
It's very hard that I I've seen an article that says there is a negative
correlation,
even for sure they are smart people in the top of competitive programming are
very smart. But on the other hand, uh,
they are maybe over skilled in algorithms that isn't that
important in a job. What is important that you implement carefully,
that you are able to do back stuff? This, uh,
I think this is easy for competitive programmers. They make a lot of mistakes,
so they need to collect, uh, corrected all the time. Uh,
but there are some skills that they don't have and they are good candidates and
some of them will be awesome workers. Some of them will not.
That makes sense. That makes sense.
So what are like the biggest contests and platforms for a company?
I already mentioned coat versus this is restaurant platform.
There is also Japanese art coder, uh, American Topcoder,
which is a very old platform, like almost 20 years. It was one of the first,
well,
the other two are quite young and they organize contests online
every week. I think.
So if you combine all those platforms plus several that I didn't mention,
you will have contests every second day or so.
Plus there are some big onsites from time to time like Google couch,
Topcoder open Facebook, hacker cup.
Some of them are just organized by big companies to attract skilled
participants and to maybe hire them.
A Google code jam actually is I think the well prepared
one, I also, we've a stream,
quite professional stream that has a lot of advertisement.
And you already know that they will advertise Google stadia this year during the
stream, but it's also for programmers.
So there's a lot of clips work with us. This is echo intern.
Please tell us what you do and why you like Google.
It's like one big advertisement.
Of course still I don't complain because I get to compete with other strong
competitors. I have a chance to win money and I have a trip to yes.
Yeah, that's true. Oh, did he pay for your flight here? Yes. What about hotel?
They cover hotel sometimes five star one. Uh,
so I've been to few five star hotels only because
competition's paid for that.
Well, what's the prize for like first place, second place.
Right now it's around 10,000 or $15,000,
which is fine. Especially if you live not in a rich country in Europe,
it's more for example in pond, but it used to be so much more,
really even $100,000 for doing, why is it so low right now?
I think, but this is only my fault. Uh,
that may be because once you in such money,
you don't have an incentive to work in their company.
Cause they're trying to recruit.
Yeah. Google wants to get those,
those people so that they shouldn't give them money.
Okay. Maybe, uh, just a side question.
Do you use to do math competition?
I did. I actually in high school Thiel, maybe middle of high school.
I did maps instead of informatics. And I went to some international.
On-sites maybe not as big as Google cogent, but yes, I was,
I think one of the best in Poland on my year. Nice.
And a lot of people in competitive programming are very good in maps.
Some of them didn't study computer science, they studied maths or economics.
So is it very similar solving for these math questions and solving for coding
questions?
I think the skills required to comprehend all of that,
to understand the logic implications,
to prove that something will work are similar. I see you,
you need a lot of knowledge that is only for algorithms,
but the same people are good in both. Okay.
Yeah.
Do people usually do competitive programming during university and then do they
stop after it? Because it seems like everyone's so young.
Yeah. Most of people are yang. Uh,
maybe also because competitive programming almost didn't exist 20 years ago.
Now they're only a few guys that are in the top and over 30,
most of people study a lot in high school maybe, uh,
to prepare for IOI if they are very competitive and skillful in university for
ICPC competition or just to get to some company
because interviews are also about algorithms.
So competitive programming is maybe a place to, to try,
uh, to, to learn a bit, to compare yourself with others. Uh,
plus there are competitions like Google kickstart that are more mainstream for
programmers. And you have a chance to that.
If you are good to their Google might invite you to an interview.
And after university, once you have a job already, maybe you start a family,
you don't have time anymore to practice like several hours a week.
Then why would you continue that? That's true.
Some people still do because they enjoy it, but not a lot of them. Yeah.
Yeah.
I personally think it's a lot easier to just apply to these jobs
normally than winning a competition.
Do you think the coding questions for the interviews are similar to the
competitive programming questions or is it way easier?
Hm. So regarding the first question, how easy it is to get for competitions.
It's not that you have to win like Google kickstart to be invited top 200,
maybe even top 500 is enough that you can say that while applying and
maybe they will give you the first interview because of that. Oh, okay.
Still you will quickly fail if you are in good, maybe in other areas.
Uh, but it's a chance to be recognized compared to thousands of people,
maybe tens of thousands, uh, and problems are similar.
Competitive programming is harder, uh,
because it's for people that train sometimes here is for that.
It needs to be harder. Uh,
but there are just some differences while competitive programming requires some
complicated algorithms.
Coding interviews sometimes can ask you questions that aren't possible to be
tested with computer. Like maybe some parallel computing,
we've thousands of machines.
You will not meet such a problem in competitive programming because organizers
don't want to get thousands of machines to test your program.
Google organized such a competition when we've hundreds of machines testing your
program, but it had some limitations. It was called distributed culture,
core coding interviews have also sometimes other problems that can not appear
in competitive programming. Uh, like for example,
inventing an algorithm that we work in constant time for something like our
invigorating attack,
given an RA binary search some number because the RA started,
it's very hard to test with competitive programming because you need to get that
ROI anyway.
So the time spent by computer or checker for that needs to be at
least the linear complexity. Anyway,
when you speak with somebody during interview, they can ask you,
what about this? Can you achieve smaller memory?
Maybe try to get constant memory while program that is automatically
judged. Sometimes has some limitations.
Like you cannot distinguish between complexities also then constant factor
matters.
So th the fact that everything is tested has the downside of not being
able to distinguish everything, but also has an advantage.
Everything is fair and objective. It's not that interviewer likes you.
So he gave you better skirt.
Yeah. Quick question. So in competitive programming,
does it ever happen that the higher complexity is actually better
because the lower, sorry, the higher complex.
What you said to make sense? Like the,
the higher complexity might be faster and better.
Because like the constant is too high for like the lower complexity does that.
Yes. It might happen. I,
you need to understand when you want to focus on competitive programming,
you want, you need to understand, for example,
that hashtag hash maps have quite high, constant factor.
If you can evolve, these are small. Anyway,
they would fit in an RA, use an error. Instead,
everything will be constant access anyway, but it's faster.
So this is one example. And the other is that maybe some complexities,
theoretically worse,
but because of small data actually like this,
even though it's an square, because any small, you don't care about it,
you don't have to invent [inaudible].
So people don't check your code during competitions, right. They just run it.
Even, it might happen that tests are very weak.
Like they do not cover some case, like maybe edge case,
or maybe your algorithm is hubristic and it could be quadratic.
But when data is random,
then for some reason there are some algorithms like that.
And organizers tried to care about that pessimistic runtime.
And they try to create as cases, malicious test cases,
but they don't always succeed. It's impossible to predict all the answers.
They have a hard job. So.
Do people ever win because they realize the tests aren't that good.
So they could make their code, like even not cover all the edge cases,
but then win because of that.
It might happen, especially during class minutes of a competition or, you know,
already that you will not have time to come up with a solution.
So you're just throwing whatever it's maybe like in school writing sub essay,
maybe marking year, the answers by random. Okay. A C B I,
maybe it will pass. And just once every 10 or a hundred at times it will.
Cool. Cool. Cool. So you have the, you have personally met Kennedy, right?
Yes. I have my team. Right. Can you get him here?
Yeah. I think you would need to write to him like a few weeks ago.
Oh, really? Uh, shoot. Okay. Well he is coming in a Google code jam,
right? Yep.
But you know,
usually you plan those trips a few months in advance and you already have
tickets. So there's nothing now that you can do. Oh, well, you know,
some people actually will be here already in advance
because I asked, uh, several guys very,
they maybe want to go to escape room together in San Jose. That's fine.
[inaudible] easy for you guys. Uh, yeah.
I think people in competitive programming are very good in SQL.
And so I'm going to with several strong guys and psychosis,
I think that if there are some algorithmic problems as us,
we will be very good, but he's not one of them. Sorry for that.
Yeah. So, uh, what about any other, uh, competitors?
Like do they all, are they all in school? What did they do for a living?
The best ones are those that still after university, they do something.
Of course they are some very skillful and talented, uh,
once in high school or a university.
But if some other people have 10 years of experience already, they're better.
Those that enjoy the competitive programming and they want to practice for
the sake of it. Uh, because they like it.
And some of them work in university like doing research in algorithms sometimes
in machine learning. I know,
I feel guys that started companies or startups on their own,
or like they do cool stuff like that.
I don't compete anymore. Right.
They do some of it, you know, it's,
they cannot spend 20 hours a week,
but if they like something and their job is a bit related to that,
it's good for them to stay fresh with algorithms,
new algorithms in the world. Uh,
then they can spend several hours a week and it's still useful to some degree.
Some people work in Europe, in university, some in big companies like Google.
They're also people like me that just stay in competitive program.
It's a bit like questioning in school. Why do you need biology for,
and the question is to teach your children.
Of course, there are some users.
And I also had internships where I just strictly did
augers, like working on algorithm in a company,
selling flight tickets, working on algorithm to
combine single flights into something we've changed.
You don't do that with machine learning because there is just,
let's say thousands of possible sites and you need to combine them in
good enough complexity.
This is exactly a problem that could appear in the programming context.
Interesting.
So do you mind me asking like how old you are and when you started competitive
programming?
I am right now, 24. And I started,
I think when I was around 16, 16,
I knew some of C plus plus maybe just starting to be tough
Peyton, uh, when I was 16 and when I was 17 or 18,
I bought my first book. I'm not from a big city,
so it's not that I had a lot of friends to discuss with or to learn from.
Uh, also, uh, not a lot of teachers know programming,
like algorithmic programming. You only in university learned that. Uh,
well I bought a book Carmen's introduction to algorithms.
I've read most of that and I could do it because I was good in maths.
So then my, my skills, my performance,
I think skyrockets also then university meeting,
other talented people, uh, competing with them in team ICPC,
competition and.
Curiously. That's pretty cool. That's pretty cool. What about, uh, again,
like when did he start and like, how old is he now?
I think he started when he was like six we've called him when he was
11 for the first time he was in international Olympiad for high school.
And I think for the first time when he was there, he didn't win.
He won when he was 12. Okay.
Wait, how old is he now?
My age or maybe one year older. I think he's 25.
He's even don't don't quote me on that.
Okay. Okay. That's cool. So what do you plan to do in the future?
Like do you think you just want to teach competitive programming or do you want
to do something else? You know, what, if everything paid the same,
every job paid the same. What would you choose?
Can I just play games on PS4? You have to stream it.
Okay. Okay.
So I guess you liked playing games on PS4.
Yes.
But algorithms are also called if I were to chose just till the end of my life
to do algorithms are play games.
I would choose algorithms because those are more interesting to me, core core.
It's called to do some of this and some of that. Uh, yeah.
If everybody paid this, if everything paid the same,
then I for sure would continue with my YouTube channel where, uh,
for now I don't even have ads. So I earned zero, uh,
for now, for that. And it's,
I don't think it will change a lot in the near future. Uh,
but I know that I helped some people.
I receive messages that they like me, if it is that they learn something.
Also sometimes I try coding interview problems just to bring more people to
competitive programming. This is something that people search for.
And then maybe some of them will just enjoy algorithms and will stay there.
I also organize camps, um,
teach in high school, some S um, yeah,
also from the organizations site, I'm not only teacher,
but also organizer organizer of contests events.
And I liked that I will be doing that in the future.
Cool. Cool. All right. Well, thank you so much for coming. Uh,
do you want to talk your channel a little bit promoted or something?
Yeah. So basically, if, if you want to learn algorithms,
then it's a good idea to check each other out, but I guess that's it.
The name of my channel is Arista we've C H R E C
H T.
How did you come up with that username?
Cause that's the same as our competitive programming.
Yeah. Uh,
I use Erika in the internet and a lot of people ask me about the meaning of
that.
And the answer is it's a bunch of random letters and there is huge advantage to
that. It's never taken the,
if you take something from a book or a, like your name, something like this,
it will be taken.
Yeah. That's funny. Cool. All right. Thank you so much for the interview.
I appreciate it learned a lot. Thank you so much. See ya.
Squarespace gives people a powerful and beautiful platform in which you can
create your website.
You can create beautiful websites or an online store using these award-winning
templates, create beautiful websites with Squarespace all in one platform.
So that means you'll never have to install things, patch things,
or upgrade ever.
Squarespace is used by a wide range of creatives and people ranging from
musicians, designers, artists, restaurants, YouTubers, and more.
If you're interested,
go on squarespace.com/joe Mattec to get your free trial
and 10% off your first purchase. All right. That's it.